I'm sorry to interrupt this meme review
with a special pew news new segment CNN
recently reported there's been an
outbreak of ligament so if you're at
home right now you haven't heard about
this I highly recommend you talk to your
parents you study and read up on this to
do whatever you can to protect yourself
own leg month I know this is me in
review and I'm supposed to make memes or
whatever but I want to be responsible
here a lot of people have been trying to
meme League my like it's some sort of
joke not funny ok if there's one thing
you need to know by leg my Felix what is
like my number one leg ma is not Joe ok
85% of humanity has died of ligament I
don't understand how anyone can sing
solo make fun of people dying dying is
like top 5 what were one of the worst
things so I don't I why anyone would
make fun of this leg my thing I don't
get it my friend Ethan Klein passed away
of leg ma do you think this is some sort
of joke honestly it's really upsetting I
know I mean a lot on this channel but
there's also a time to be serious and
that is now let me tell you okay this
might be shocking news to everyone my
favorite fortnight's streamer ninja has
passed away of leg my and I know what
you're thinking
Isis sucks Who am I gonna watch play
fortnight now there's barely anyone
playing that game
Legba is a serious disease and if it's
not treated seriously you could end up
hurt
[Music]
rule number two never ask what league my
is that's what ninja did and that's what
caused his demise
ninja mob Kali GG f I thought you died
from leg muscles
what Seligman ladies and gentlemen but
just because of this joke everyone
started spamming ninja ligament so the
ninja had to start banning people let's
start banning although the Lima stop
please
just like a start with like a 24-hour
ban and then just go straight to bans
why would you ban people from trying to
spread awareness of lignin this is so
set if this video gets 5,000 likes we
could pure League my right now I would
never ban people from spreading
awareness of lignin hey the test results
came back it's not good you have Laidlaw
Lima
leave my balls internet celebrities left
and right are hit by ligament I'm here
to protect them okay you might say oh
this is pretty low over you Felix I'm
trying to protect people so they don't
end up like ninja just look at ET a
young dirt actor a young pop star with a
bright future look at him now ninja you
can't defeat me me I know but he can
lick my balls
the life of successful people such as
ninja and supreme pati
league much what are they afraid of
vampires sir tonight Superman kryptonite
internet celebrities League mud Alexa
can we play off dog
not much what about you the league my
mean gets a four point it's not gonna
work anymore but it worked on the top
streamer ninja and he got really salty
about it which makes it fun that's the
only reason why it's funny it's because
he got upset about it instead of instead
of
[Music]
we live in a time where free thinkers
are truly truly thriving Greek
philosophers excuse me go away
all right you will never be on the level
of such as trying markiplier videos
Jordan B Peterson social justice warrior
own combinations only lip tars but the
top of the top of the greatest freest
thinkers of this planet world universe
etc are roblox
commenters do you see roblox has a
censoring system where you can't comment
certain words so they have to run an
extra mile up here and they do it at
ease to express themselves in a savage
way and the most savage way even
possible delivering the thickest burn of
all time so chest go commit die
oof if you get hit by that I don't
there's no that's worse than leg ma
definitely or perhaps go commit not
alive ah I will swear word at you I will
swear word at you oh yeah why don't you
commit neck rope oh oh this gets me
hyped it's just me going go commit stop
living damn damn son he got you good
he got you good Luigi you do or gay
Lowell ah son ah
son you gots destroyed you got pooped on
do you are have stupid or something ah
ah
man those roblox commenters sure know
how to get you stop being having autism
hmm or the strongest of them all if you
get hit by any of these comments at any
points there's only one thing and one
thing only that you must do you must
commit suicide
[Music]
hopefully the YouTube bought doesn't
misunderstand what I'm saying and I can
finally I finally figured out a way to
express myself
thanks to roblox commenters thank you I
thank you you got a four as well
congratulations roblox you've done well
there's not really that much too many
memes I think the league my thing just
really took over
but there is one meme if I truly have
the power to kill means there's one mean
I want to just die okay I never want to
see it again is this stupid blackout
white mean it's this stupid meme okay
anytime I see it I want to die
stop posting these what is this what
we're in the same shirt Phil don't do a
lot of damage to that bucket please stop
wow the graphics and roblox look back
they truly have increased impressive the
only thing I appreciate about this meme
is the minimalistic aesthetic of it this
is what a [ __ ] would read XY XY XY XY
Eckerd what does this mean me and
intellectual those XS is about to get it
wait isn't it isn't xx the mail no way
Oh mail is XY and idiot would say wow
they looks like he didn't finish his
cereal to me and intellectual that white
one is about to get in dammit
I can't even eat Oreos anymore it's
completely ruin it for me I can't watch
my favorite Disney movie Tarzan anymore
it's completely ruined for me
I can't even appreciate Asian agent
hieroglyphic paintings
I can't even appreciate their
monetization anymore it's completely
ruined for me I can't even
okay okay this is epic
minecraft dad Disney kids watch Disney
are you sick
dices dices play kids are you okay
Pokemon Pokemon Japanese what happened
to me so bad this room gets a zero so
would have died it kills all my favorite
things
this is a for me where you hope you get
but Felix you didn't review sick oh man
what's a circle me suck on my balls
[Music]
like right now in this video subscribe
hit the bell button and I'll see you
guys you've just been phill'd in and I
see you guys in the next meme review
[Music]
[Applause]